make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and in today's episode of our beyond
omega level series we're going to
discuss
a cosmic character that i would imagine
many of you have never heard of but who
is one of the most powerful cosmic
entities
to ever appear in marvel comics also a
lot of you guys have requested that we
do more beyond
omega level stuff for dc comics you guys
got it uh here's the thing the term
beyond omega level is strictly a marvel
term
but we use it as a general term to
describe characters and comics that are
just ridiculously overpowered
dc as far as i'm aware doesn't really
have a power classification in the same
way that marvel does and even marvel
didn't have it for a long time right the
only reference you had to beyond omega
level or likes omega level itself was
like some reference to rachel summers
back during the era of chris claremont
it wasn't until grant morrison took over
with new x-men that you actually started
getting a kind of hierarchical structure
of powerful characters in relation to
the mutant population and then marvel
expanded that out and they started
calling them
omega level threats if they were equal
to be or equal to omega level mutants
but were not mutants themselves right so
uh so there's just kind of a clear
little uh to clear that up a little bit
but yeah we can do more dc comic stuff a
lot of you guys have asked for that
there's no reason not to so tyrant was
created by ron mars and ron lim and
first appeared in silver surfer number
81 in 1993. now within the continuity of
marvel comics tyrant was actually
created by galactus
shortly after the creation of the
universe when he felt the first pangs of
insatiable hunger that would lead him to
become the devourer of worlds now we
don't know exactly why galactus decided
to create a living machine
whether he wanted a companion of
comparable power or just to prove that
he could or he got bored or just
whatever the reason he ended up creating
tyrant in his own
image tyrant however soon grew jealous
of galactus and unlike his creator was
not satisfied in consuming
just what he needed to survive but
instead developed a desire for conquest
and subjugation
which really you would think galactus
would have seen this coming when he
decided to create somebody
named tyrant but anyway tyron ends up
conquering several worlds including the
homeworld of the spencer hood an ancient
order of female
warriors and as we learn in tyrant's
first appearance from a member of the
spencer hood named ganymede tyron
had been conquering worlds for centuries
in a war that spanned multiple galaxies
before the spencer hood rallied to
defeat him but this does not make much
sense because
ganymede describes tyrant as being nigh
omnipotent so it doesn't really seem
possible for a bunch of warriors with
energy rods to be able to defeat him and
later
we learn that they actually didn't while
tyrant did disappear
it was actually galactus who upon
discovering tyron had been conquering
and enslaving worlds
attacked him resulting in a battle that
according to thanos likely destroyed
entire galaxies now although galactus
ultimately defeated tyrant
tyrant was able to prove a worthy foe
for his creator and so following this
victory
galactus stripped tyrant of much of his
power and he seemingly disappeared from
the universe now after thousands of
years tyron ends up returning and the
trail of energy he leaves leads the
silver surfer in ganymede to his
fortress from which he'd ruled his vast
empire millennia ago now once they make
their way through the fortress and
encounter tyron he defeats them
easily and imprisons them alongside
gladiator of the shiar
vader ray bill terrax and morg who was
the herald of galactus at that point in
time now the fact that tyron was able to
subdue and imprison such ridiculously
powerful entities
is quite impressive especially when you
consider that silver surfer and
gladiator are probably beyond omega
level themselves and an argument could
be made for the others being at or
beyond omega level as well but when we
learn that tyrant plans to siphon the
energy of his prisoners to power his
army of mechanical warriors to once
again reclaim the empire he'd lost
tyrant's minions then bring in another
prisoner
the jack of hearts who expels all his
energy to free his fellow prisoners who
immediately go after tyrant now much
their surprise silver surfer's energy
blasts
do not seem to affect tyrant at all and
he's equally unfazed by an attack from
vader ray bill using his hammer's
stormbreaker as well as the energy beams
of gladiator now as the battle rages on
it's clear the tyrant
more than outclasses even the combined
efforts of all of his foes as he handles
the silver surfer vader ray bill
gladiator and ganymede without breaking
much of a sweat and so tyron's victory
is ultimately short-lived as his creator
galactus arrives to have words with his
creation and it's here that we learned
that galactus took the action that he
did
in defeating and depowering tyrant
because he viewed tyron as a threat to
the universe's stability and so that
lets us know how powerful of an entity
that we're dealing with here and even
now
galactus is hesitant to engage tyron in
battle acknowledging that doing so would
be damaging
to not only the both of them but the
entire galaxy itself
and so galactus actually goes as far as
to allow tyrant to keep his herald morg
as a power source to avoid getting into
a conflict with him although he vows to
deal with tyrant at a later date and so
we would next see tyrant cross paths
with another cosmic mainstay of the
marvel landscape
in the mad titan thanos so in the mini
series called cosmic powers
thanos teams up with ganymede jack of
hearts terrax and captain marvel to
venture to tyrant's fortress
and it's at this point that thanos
discovers tyrant's origin as the
creation of galactus but what is more
interesting is that the two of them
actually fight one another and the two
of them battle to a stalemate before
thanos leaves the battlefield having
obtained what he came for an
orb containing the power cosmic the
tyrant had been siphoning from mork and
although thanos seems to think himself
the victor of the battle
he didn't actually appear to damage
tyrant in any meaningful way
and so tyron continues to hold morg
prisoner and sends him back to galactus
with mental implants designed to control
him and so morgan manages to overcome
tyron's control and during tyrant's
final battle with galactus morg obtains
and uses the ultimate nullifier one of
the most powerful objects in the marvel
universe and the only thing that
galactus fears and once the ultimate
nullifier is detonated
tyrant seems to be completely and
totally destroyed and hasn't really been
seen in the marvel universe
since and this was back in 1995 so we
haven't seen tyron in a quarter of a
century in a medium notorious for
bringing back characters from the dead
multiple times and i think that's why
tyrant despite being powerful enough to
battle galactus and subjugate multiple
worlds to his rule
is a character that slipped through the
cracks and not a lot of people know
about but with that being said guys
that's really the
the best display of tyrant's power right
normally we go through like a list of
the things that they've achieved and all
that kind of stuff but like literally
the guy took out the totality of the
annihilators and galactus was afraid to
fight him i think that kind of speaks
for itself
i think that demonstrates beyond omega
level classification so if you guys are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
again
uh feel free to post some dc comic book
characters that you guys want to see me
cover in beyond
omega level because admittedly we have
really only ever been focusing on marvel
for a long long time and that's one of
the things that people noticed actually
on the twitch stream it's one of the
requests that people had right where we
just live streamed comics explained 24
7.
a lot of people had requested that in
the beyond omega level series uh and
even in the character explanation series
that we focus more on dc characters as
opposed to just
largely being marvel and that's fair so
i'll do my best to bring you guys more
dc comic stuff post some suggestions
down in the comments section i'll have
my writer take a look at him and he can
kind of pick through and start making
videos or start writing scripts for you
guys so that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
cry with me
[Music]
stupid
me